[موسيقى] أجنبية ،
المياه الصافية لشرق البحر الأبيض
المتوسط ​​هنا في تركيا ،
يسمونها الساحل الفيروزي ، ويمكنك
بالتأكيد معرفة السبب ، وفي هذا
المكان الجميل ستجد
أحد أصعب ملاعب الجولف في
تركيا lykia و  اليوم سأقوم
بتناولها
شكرًا
كما ترون
أنها رائعة فقط إنها واحدة من
دورات Lynx الوحيدة في البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​التي
نحن محظوظون بوجودها في تركيا ، لذا
انظر فقط إلى هذا المنظر ، إنه
رائع للغاية اليوم  دليلي إلى ليكيا
هو إدوارد لامبري ، محترف الجولف المتقدم ،
مدرب سابق
لمنتخب تركيا الوطني ومؤسس مشارك في شركة
غولف جنون ، وهي شركة سفريات وفعاليات
تجذب السياح إلى تركيا شورز
وفيروايز ، ربما سمعت عن بيت يموت
أحد أعظم مصممي  طوال الوقت ،
كان مميزًا جدًا في
ثقوب توقيعه ، فهو يحب استخدام عوارض السكك الحديدية
في المخابئ وأعتقد أنه
استمتع حقًا بتصميم المدارس وقطعة
أرض رائعة للعمل معها ، لقد
ترك لنا بالتأكيد بعض
التحديات التي يمكنني أن أرى بعضًا منها أعمى.
الكثير والكثير من التموجات ،
تبدو الخضر صعبة حقًا ،
وهي واحدة من الدورات التدريبية المفضلة لدي
في تركيا بالتأكيد ،
يقع مسار روابط الخمور المكون من 18 حفرة على 60 هكتارًا
من الأرض ومن كل نقطة تقريبًا من
الدورة يمكنك الاستمتاع بها  هذه
المناظر الخلابة للبحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​،
برأيك ، ما الذي تحمله إمكانات لعبة
الجولف في تركيا ، كما تقول ، ينمو
بمعدل مثير للإعجاب عندما
نزلت لأول مرة ، كانت مجرد
وجهة شتوية صغيرة والآن أنت
تعرف واحدة من  الوجهات الرئيسية
بالتأكيد في أوروبا
كوجهة شتوية ، يمكنك رؤية
الطقس اليوم ملبدًا بالغيوم قليلاً ولكن
لا يزال رائعًا لشهر مارس ، نحن في بقية
أوروبا ، يمكن أن تكون Mucky قليلاً ،
لذا فبالتأكيد
إنها وجهة شتوية تتزايد.  بسرعة
ومع وجود 17 دورة ، ربما
لا يكفيهم في الواقع لبناء المزيد من
الأراضي التي يحتاجون إليها للعثور على المزيد من الأراضي
والتحدث عن سياحة الجولف
على وجه التحديد ، فأنت تقوم بالفعل
بالكثير من العمل لجلب السياح إلى تركيا ، أليس كذلك؟
الكثير من
بطولات الجولف بعضًا من أكبر
البرامج في العالم وبطولات الهواة ،
ونحن وكالة سفر
أيضًا ، لذا
نعم لدينا
أسواق مختلفة في بلدان مختلفة
وننمو في هذا الصدد لذلك
نجلب الكثير من الأشخاص  ألف في
السنة إلى تركيا وما هي رسومهم عندما
يأتون إلى هنا خاصة بالنسبة لأول
توقيت إيجابي بشكل لا يصدق
كما ترون عادة الطقس
رائع ، ملاعب الجولف في
رأيي لا مثيل لها خاصة الأشخاص الذين
اعتادوا الذهاب إلى إسبانيا
والبرتغال لا يزالون  وجهات رائعة
ولكن أعتقد أن اللغة التركية تقدم أكثر من ذلك بكثير
في حقيقة أن جميع
الدورات التدريبية في غضون 30 دقيقة من بعضها
البعض ، كما تعلم ،
نعم جميل أعتقد أنه نصف ،
شكرًا لك حقًا في التاسع عشر على ما
أعتقد تمامًا
[موسيقى]